hello chess fans how is it going hope
you're having a good day
i uh made some adjustments so i moved
around a little
like with the chair and the setup so i
could get
this guy in the frame because he's been
so cute recently i just
i realized he had to there we go he's
putting up a show already
i realized he would um prefer to be in
the
screen but yeah so sorry
for the little delay we got this going
on hopefully he'll continue to be all
cute
and not at all distracting uh
throughout our today lesson i yeah
i um i was looking at some of the games
that
uh has been going on and i really have
wanting
have been wanting to shares a lot on
dragon
and so um i realized that
i had this somewhat cute games going on
uh a long long long time ago it feels
like a whole different lifetime
and so i wanted to share these to be
fair i've had some pretty horrible
losses in dragon as well
so it's not all rainbows and dragons
but um some of these have been very cute
so i really have
uh i think this these three games that
i've selected
will give you somewhat of an idea on
different things that you can look for
in dragon
especially as white um
today uh we are going to be talking
about taming your dragon
literally dragon opening with my mini
baby
dragon up here being all cute it really
feels cute i liked having him on the
screen
all right um let's go ahead and get
started
so uh the first one that i want to show
you
is with uh
it was a very funny game because from
what i remember he was like
yay hi this game was like seven years
eight years ago i'm old
yeah and uh as you can see
uh he was he is younger than me he had
higher rated it's still the same
thing he is uh one of the um
young stars from iran so i thought it
would be cool to
show this also makes me feel better you
know i beat this guy
he was a little kid yay only if i bet
fioruzzo when he was a kid
would have would have been a nice
collection um
all right let's go ahead uh so
it's a dragon that's not a secret
but what is uh what was a little
surprising
was this opening that i played here
well i usually uh for dragon i've i
don't think
i gave the short castle ideas a little
try it
really did bore me so i decided to
switch it up a little bit
uh so i think all three of these games
that you will see have different
openings which is kind of why i'm
showing these
but i think it's a good idea to try and
have multiple different
lines against specific openings
so all right especially
especially when playing uh players that
you know
like if you don't know the opponent you
can't prepare ah makes sense
but if you know the opponent and you
have the chance to prepare against him
then you should and as i i believe i
didn't prefer specifically against
um muhammad i mean because i mean i knew
him but i wasn't
exactly um like i wasn't sure what he
would play
this is what i played at the time and
there are a lot of different
ways to go about this like i think h5 is
one of the most annoying ways
uh trying to get like whoops trying to
do like bishop v6 is another annoying
way those two
are what i remember i remember h5 was
something that's
whoa my my mouse is going cuckoo all
right ah
i remember h5 why is my mouse calling
cuckoo
ah i remember h5 there we go it's
something that's kind of a
bothersome idea but
in the game he took now i want to take a
second and ask you guys to evaluate this
position so what do you think is this a
um is this a doable idea not a doable
idea
did black rush it did black do just
enough
and yes it is a very very nice layout
i strategically moved everything around
the table
to get exactly this frame
oh yes yugoslav is um
that's one of the ways to go about it
so any ideas on how to continue with
this
well obviously you would most likely
want to take so that's not the exact
question
but
okay i see he rushed it to be fair uh
taking
is a possibility but it's so
um it's so much theory
that uh at some point i don't know if it
was worth playing it
so now uh why would you want to play
bishop g1
ah jesus there's a
mouse going crazy
so yeah uh also let me know the cities
that you're at
or states or countries how is the uh
crazy storm at where you're at
because here it's pretty crazy they
canceled school for like monday and
tuesday and today was like our
february break one day in my opinion
just cancel the next two days already
especially because i have a very very
hard exam tomorrow
that i still need to study for actually
learned for let's go with that so yeah
please cancel school
wow england you returned to school 8th
of march
jeez nice
well yes that is one of the things ah
that is one of the things jesus
oh yeah well to be fair i did drop this
mouse earlier today
whoops maybe that's why it's acting out
yes taking is one of the ways to go
well let's just think what does what
does my opponents want right now
does my opponent who probably wants to
take over here and eat this light right
so what we do should be related to
saving this night so either i would have
to take
or go away
nobody wants to play night knight to b3
interesting
i thought knight b3 would have more
suitors
i wish we were not going to school most
of my classes
are online anyways but
there are few that are in person i'm not
the fan okay
so you would try to save your bishop i
wouldn't exactly recommend this
just because now maybe something like e6
and then the queen is also getting
opened up
you can't really castle because there's
bishop h6
so you have to be very careful with
where how you go about it
bishop g4 is not the best idea but it's
a very tricky idea
sacrifice so you should be able to
follow
um strongly you can't just do whatever
you
want a nice b3 isn't a strong idea
knight taking on c6 is another
possibility
but my problem with this is that black's
piece activity is a little too much
i don't know how what to do with my
pieces in this position
like if i do something like that then oh
next thing you know checks left and
right
whoops checks left and right and then
this guy is coming yeah it's not
i don't yeah it's not really worth it
i'm gonna have a really hard time
developing so i have to be very careful
with my piece
with my opponent's piece activity so i
thought knight p3 was a cool idea trying
to cover
no more queen a5s no bishop h6 at the
moment
i see i also said that the chat seems to
be warming up to the idea of knight v3
now in the game uh he played d5
he played d5 what do we think is d5 good
is d5 too early
all right i see some people are agreeing
it's good okay
um so the problem is even if you took
over here i would simply take
back it doesn't really help black's
position
even if i mean you're gonna get the
chance to castle and i don't really know
black's
knight was um didn't really have any
problems i don't i mean he
i don't think i don't think black needs
to rush this
i wish i was peachy too sleeping right
now sleeping is always good especially
in snowy days oh
man all right so d5 what do we what
what should we do should we take this
what should we take it with we got two
different choices i'm not going to say
queen because i don't want to lose my
bishop
yeah i think we should take that too but
the thing is if you take it with the
knife then bishop b2 and your king is
going to be quite unsafe
that's why we shouldn't take it with the
um
with the knights because now i don't
know where to place my king
so that's why taking pawn is the best
idea
and now it's quite interesting because
black's gonna get the chance to
take c3 and you
are again in a little bit of pickle if
you take with queen
queen takes d5 and attacks your rug and
stops your castle
but if you take with the pawn
this similar thing just minus the um
minus the queen being on c3 and your
pawns are doubled
so which one do you think is better
should we take with pawn or queen
all right i see a lot of people saying
queen to be fair i did take with the
queen
myself too that was not the best choice
because when i took with the queen now
my opponent could easily equalize
and he did take rook g1 and queen e4
now cleaning for is kind of um
like the little issue going on here
so
yeah that that's like a little bit of an
issue with
queen e4 trying to um
deal with this king
unsafe unsafe king as well as
now my bishop being under attack being
unable to develop my other bishop
so that's why taking with pawn would
like
save a little bit more of my
time not because i could take well i
mean technically i could take that but
it's not
as ideal anymore anyways because still
black has a pretty sweet attack going on
now um but taking over
taking over here you take on d5
rook g1 and you don't really have that
queen e4s anymore
next move i can try to get my bishop out
get my rooks out
try to form something a little bit
better
all right um so tier
after take i took with queen queen e4
what do you think we should do
as white
let me get my coffee close by
well we can't just cast though i don't
want to lose my bishop
yeah rook g3 good job trying to save
your bishop
so now after we're going to g3
um black still has pretty awesome piece
activity now i want you to think for
black
what move from black could really be
bothersome
because if it's white and white wants to
castle so what can black
do to um kind of
prevent me oh thank you i'm manny i
believe the red background was
been a ben simon's idea it was a while
ago
but i've kind of been like covering it
up all together
but this new frame with this his majesty
right here
being super cute fine fine
i'll tickle you
that's so cute i like working from home
honestly just because of peachy well
also the cold but
if it was summer and peachy was
coming everywhere with me as usual yeah
all right so i see the idea of a dirk d8
i
do like this idea um
the problem with rook d8 is that it's
too slow
whichever still pretty slow because i
would have bishop g2 i would have knight
d2 it's too
slow so think of more um
as black maybe think of yeah all right i
see some knight i see
someone said knight b4 yeah
knight b4 going after this pawn if you
cast el there is
knight takes a2 as well bye bye queen
so what should we do after knights b4
also i'd like to mention my e3 is a
possibility because when you take with
the rook
there is a clean edge for check and if
you tried rook g3
now something was drifting to try and
stop this
also queen is too happening if you try
to do like a knight d2
again like a rook c8 just look at this
awesome peace activity or maybe a knight
d4
you try to castle there is rook c8
it's so scary for white
so that was another possibility but i
think knight b4
is pretty easy to find now what do you
think we should do as white we can't
castle
just yet at least
d5 was a good move d5 was
uh giving black much more chances of
trying to
figure out how to activate his pieces
so
all right i see some suggestions on
uh bishop to d3
bishop g2 knight d4 a lot of those so
well i wouldn't really go for bishop g2
honestly in my c2 is it still pretty
annoying
um
so let's not go for that let's go for
i like the idea of just bishop d3
it stops a lot of these problems and if
you take it
perfect i'll just take with the queen
and that is actually what happened in
the game
uh in the game he also just kind of
um took with the queen
but he could have done queen h1 that's
another possibility
but then i would have done like bishop
g1 or rook 31 and next move castle so
not much difference honestly but
maybe just the um this idea of like
knight going to b4 made it a little
easier for me to develop because
remember in this line would
take and queen h4 if true goes to g3
then like rook d8 this would have been
much
more effective because even if i try to
do one of my bishop d3 normal stuff
again i can't castle it's like so
so much of a great momentum yeah he's
very generous i agree
uh so yeah i think this would have been
an easier way for him to continue
because remember if when we went to 92
there was this like knight d4
trying to do rook c8s going for over
here
so yeah i think uh knight e3 would have
been the best choice to go for
but uh knights before kind of made it a
little easier for me
now this is still this is
still going on it's still a fight but he
made like the super cool mistake of
taking on
h2 and i just played bishop g1 and
his knight went into my belly basically
yeah and then this was kind of easy to
win it was quite funny because he
continued to another like
a lot actually how did i let this game
go for so long
yeah um this game was like super winning
because you know i got two pieces
he's eating a lot of ponds though i
don't like that
all right i'm just going to continue for
a little bit longer on this game
because it's a little sad that i didn't
win it faster
all right um i mean i'm doing a good
technique right i
put my bishop here i kind of make your
pawns go uncomfortable
now let's bring out the other rock yep
well cute if i take there's rookie eight
low
um yeah let's just trying to continue
trying to eat some ponds yeah i think
i was simply just winning for most of
the game now
but um he decided to continue
for a while nothing wrong with that
if you feel like fighting you should
continue no one should
stop you from that
but yeah overall it was kind of a fun
game for me
ah little tricks low if you take
all right this game doesn't really have
much else to look at
i slowly slowly eat the ponds keep my
one pawn
two extra pieces and start
threatening checkmates where is the
checkmate
should we checkmate like bishop
6 should be coming up soon yeah yeah he
resigned here
uh well the early sacrifice is
a completely alright um
idea but i think he didn't follow up as
well as he imagined he would
so like here he made the mistake of not
playing
this knight e3 and he allowed my pizzas
to
kind of free up that was his big mistake
alright um let's go ahead any questions
on this one
to be completely fair um i'm just
showing you different
ways to play dragon g4 is one of it
bishops d4 is one of it we're gonna see
short castle is another
cool idea so you don't have to play what
i'm showing you
but um it would be pretty cool if you
actually uh know more than just one line
g4 bishop takes g4 is not the best idea
there are many other lines before you
get to that position
that you really have to take but this is
all pretty good enough
already all right
uh next game was actually kind of fun
for me
um because this game was in dubai open
if i remember
correctly yeah it wasn't dubai open
i was hunting i believe this was in 2014
so i was
hunting my wim norms and
so it was kind of fun because he was
kind of higher rated by like 300 points
he was already an i am he was such a
great player
i was having a good tournament and um
he well so was he up until then
and he um i believe like there was
another game that i played
in dragon with uh guan and jones
i got destroyed right out of the opening
and then like the next dragon that in
the tournament that i was gonna play
it was with him and i saw that he plays
dragon
and so i kind of figured out well i
remember i was looking at um different
games of
uh gwan and jones and i realized oh well
i could try and
see because he's such a huge dragon
player
he knows how to tame dragons ha so i
kind of wanted to
give it that try
yeah so i went for it f4
anyone here playing this line with f4
[Music]
anyone at all
ah too bright
all right all right i see few players
are
saying that they play this okay great
well to be completely fair it's a pretty
cool idea
not nothing against it um
but i never really
felt that strong connection with f4 i'm
a huge
f4 fan but like with white i go for f4s
with black i go for the f5s but i never
really felt that deep of a connection
with this one so it made it a little
harder for me to
um actually like it to be honest
[Applause]
alright
so after f4 no one ever plays dragon
against you wow
that is kind of well it's kind of very
interesting
i don't think i've had many players play
dragon against me
recently either yeah interesting
so knight c6 now
what should we do what's the line i kind
of want to hear
some thoughts because this is not my
main
opening so it would be kind of a good
idea to get a
better understanding of what you think
should happen
also i gotta mess with the cats
just a little paw massage
oh he's being too cute
well to be fair there are many many
different ways of playing this line
so it's not just one way bishop e3 is
one way
bishop b5 is another way
taking is possible well
trying to do short castle trying to do
long castle there are a lot of different
things to do
but in this specific game i went for
a knight to f3 i believe i went for this
knight of tree because i saw that he had
a game
that he i remember it was more of the
psychology of the preparation
rather than the exact like opening
ideas behind it so i thought that was a
cool thing to do
um yeah so anybody had anybody does this
weird knight f3
on another note
do
no um we don't really um
well the club does have a bunch of
tournaments
going on on uh leeches here and there
so make sure to follow the schedule for
that
well right now the chest club is um
still pandemic you know style
but so sadler is based so yeah
oh that reminds me i did want to
send a link and mentioned um
yeah so there is something cool going on
with the club too
um i'll be sharing the link with you
guys so maybe
hopefully you can try to enter and win
let me try to drag drop the link
now he is just napping he's being a baby
all right um yeah this my tipster is not
as popular as
most other lines um
so bishop g4 now what do you think we
should do i think the first thing to try
and decide
is what am i doing with this king
am i going short am i going long
also i really do want to drop that link
so let me work with that
oh yeah so um i'm gonna drop a link in
the chat
make sure to enter
uh hopefully you will win that will
pretty cool so we're doing like a raffle
for the 2018 santa splits and rapid to
final board signed by all the players
um the poster is on our social media
so yeah it will be pretty cool if you
guys
enter and win and then let us know that
yeah the raffle is always fun i'm a
little
scared to enter raffles but this should
be a good one try to give it a try
and he is a sleepy kitty
he's been playing in the snow most of
the day so
he's uh feeling a little
tired huh
all right so that's kind of the fun
thing about
this position you have so many different
options but one thing is pretty
pretty obvious you're most likely gonna
do short castle
because if i wanted to do lawn castle
then knight f3 didn't make
any any sense so we're gonna do short
castle
um i continued this with h3 again this
was pretty much
pre-pre-prepared before the game
i was gonna come up with a funny word
mixing with preparation
and pregame so never mind i just it was
just a
pregame preparation um
and so he took
we take and bishop g7 all right let's
get bishop d3
castle castle and knight d7 so
i have more and more question for you
guys
how do you want to continue this what
are what is your idea what are you
trying to achieve
yes i cannot stop playing with my cat
when he tries to sleep
same with him when i try to sleep he
sings he
comes and wants to cuddle and he sleeps
on my face and purrs
when i'm trying to wake up but like it's
like an alarm wake up but then i'm like
it's like oh it's alarm i still want to
go back to sleep
he comes up he like purrs on my neck he
like puts his
big belly on my face so we have a thing
going
i don't let him sleep he doesn't let me
sleep
i let him nap though
sure
oh f5 well to be fair i
f5 is like the ultimate idea but we
can't do that now this square is way too
sad a lot of things can hop in it now
this is too much
let's try to just develop
ah that was such a beautiful stretch
and he's officially covering his face
with his paw cats
bishop e3 there we go let's develop yeah
so after bishop e3
i uh my ideas were pretty simple like
man i just want to develop like i'm just
getting my pieces out it seemed like you
want
knight d4 or bishop d4 so i played
bishop e3
so this was this was kind of a chill
opening
so far so my opponent continued
with now um i think
actually let me ask you what do you
think black should do keep in mind the
last move that black played was knight
going to d7
so what do you think should be the blue
after that
oh you kind of want to get the knight to
d5 force exchange
makes sense but
um if you played knight t5
right now then there's e6 you have to
come back with your knight anyways and
then knight c5 would come
queen i5 huh i hear i mean i could live
with this yeah
definitely
so you might want to take over here
[Applause]
and do this so how about just a groupie
one
if you take the end of the line i can
try and maybe eat over here
might seem fine oh i could just take it
yeah
so rookie one makes sense queen a5 also
makes sense what else what else can
black try to do
maybe rook c8 trying to develop i kind
of like that idea too
then we could just develop ourselves as
well
i this is such a strong bishop though
black really is enjoying this white has
to try and figure out how to
um deal with that
no i'm so glad there's so many different
responses coming in so thank you
everybody for your interactions
knight c5s are right now
um not entirely the thing
just because the rook is already in
front of the queen
so e5 would become even stronger than
that
maybe it gets like queen a5 first
yeah i think this would this would most
likely work
better
all right so i see in the chat there's
some nice ideas going on about
yeah so basically you all kind of agree
that this straight between this bishop
and this knight is not really ideal for
black
i agree too black shouldn't really be
doing that
so in order for black to
uh well not do that um
well yeah
so uh i'd like to receive i think
ricochet is a good idea um in the game
my opponent played the night
before which was a little weird honestly
nice before you're attacking my bishop
but not really like my bishop is
defended
so what do you think we should do
am i supposed to move this bishop should
i come defend it should i kick the
knight
oh i see there has been some instagram
or facebook
followers interesting uh
no yeah so while you guys are
coming up with an idea on what to do
here is white
peachy uh it was not a fight fishy was
trying to make friends with the stray
cat who's been coming here
for like a good like four at least
no more like five six months now and uh
we we've been letting the other cat
inside because it's so
so freezing out there he usually eats
here stays here for like an hour and
then leaves
but last night he ate he was chilling
and pishi went a little close to him and
he was just looking at him
and the other cat just scratched fishing
and ran out
and then peachy i didn't see that i just
saw that
the they got too close i didn't see the
scratch
so i tried to go close the door on the
other cat and
see what happened to pishi and then i
saw pc came to him with like a face like
this
it was so cute and i was like oh my god
my kid went blind my cat went well
kitkat
went blind it was very sad and
uh i started like a grassroots look at
his eyes his eyes were fine and then i
was like okay so maybe
they get scratched and then i saw that
my hands were a little bloody and then i
realized that she got this huge like
scratch over here
and i did like alcohol wipes
and yeah we won't be uh
hosting this stray cat anymore
after that's shipping right fishy
anyways
yeah i don't know we we were we were
nice to this
other cats for months and kind of comes
scratches yeah ah
so honestly i do like the idea of rook
d1
i don't want to move my f rook because i
want to try and push for f5
but i like his ideas with a3 potentially
not just yet but this is something
else that's um
that's what's gonna happen so
i'm gonna try to do just get the stroke
out of the harm's way
yeah rook the one seems all right
nothing is attacking me if you take over
here
then sure i'll just take it back
and next i have d4 so i kind of do like
this i wish this actually happened
but stockfish likes
rook b1 oh god really
why would stockfish go i mean i
understand the concept of it
my pawn is weak defending no
as long as this rook d1 there no serious
threat struck d1
why would i do rook to b1
i kind of see that backward pawn
so i manic that's kind of fun that's
kind of
really funny because my opponent was
seriously considering taking over here
and i was like i'm not going to stop you
you want to give up this super cool
bishop for this weird night sure go
for it uh after druxy8
now i see a lot of you are suggesting
to form an attack in the king side as
with white i like that
we should now the question is how
just eat pond this pond uh-uh
you eat this pond there's going to be b6
even if not just yet take
take take whatever you take back with
then b6 your bishop gets in a pickle
yeah yeah don't eat poisonous pods
peachy are you sick of us
all right so not eating on a seven what
else can we try
to do f5 thank you thank you i see a lot
of you are suggesting
it files i'm not going to name names so
good job thank you f5 is great
yeah the idea with f5 is pretty cool
because
even if knight tries to go to e5 eh so
what
i'll just play queen basically anywhere
actually
g3 f4 let's go to f2 for now
if you try to take awesome i'll just try
and push d4
next move if you try to do like knight
c4
i can just even take that and just kick
you over here
my queen is defending this pawn too
nice one eye manny
um we're not gonna rush for g4 honestly
we don't want to rush it
no exactly we want to do it when needed
it's not needed right now
so i don't need to i need to torture
myself with g4
ideas
so
all right after um let's go back i don't
think
knight e5 is that necessary 95
makes sense but
something else also makes sense i'm
gonna ask you
uh what do you think it's black's best
move
i'll give you a few options maybe you
can take here
maybe you can take here um
we already looked at 95 it's doable but
doesn't really do much honestly
oh yeah this guy is gmp she
baby
all right good thank you karcher yeah i
see that the suggestion of taking a c3
is coming
in
knight e5 ii
knight to f6 i'm not sure about that
well black in the game did two knights
takes d3
that was wrong because after my takes d3
i just take c
takes d3 now i want to play d4 so he
kind of fell
into the um hole and he took over here
and we ended up in this position now
what do we think about this
is this a good idea is this a better
position for white
yeah this is a this this bishop can
become such a cool monster as it did in
the game
so i'm gonna go back and talk about the
rights move and then we're gonna come
back here and
show how the game ended
well if you want to take this you got to
take it now you shouldn't wait that long
because this bishop is kind of on the
way honestly it's not really doing
anything this bishop so you don't have
to take it you can just keep it and
consider taking other stuff that's just
not the bishop basically um because
now if you try to let's say take over
here i can just take it with
f you move the queen
even knight can maybe maybe just take
this take that
try to double up over here it's still uh
still not ideal because of this bishop
white still has pretty good compensation
for the pawn that
i've lost but it's it's still a playable
position
like black is not losing or it's not
losing nobody has that
clear advantage
another way to go about it is
potentially
with um now maybe 95
you move now i take
that's another way to go about it but it
makes white even better
um well if we don't want to take on c3
then we should go for 95. taking on c3
it's so um
yeah taking out c3 is so i'm gonna say
lazy honestly or stupid
i don't know which one to go for it's
not really a good idea it's
it doesn't make any sense to give up
this bishop
and make my bishop strong
so yeah uh knight takes take
in the game this is what happened
king gotta go to h1 knight e5 now what
should we do
also what do you think is this um
position
good idea for white black what should we
do
oh i see queen e2 why are we going back
oh wow some people still would rather to
be black
interesting
well black is not exactly offering the
rock
but the queen we gotta figure out where
to place the queen
all right i don't want to play queen e3
because i don't want to exchange the
queens
and also i would lose d3 after that i
don't want to go in the end game
the position the problem is that you
have a weak king with or
compared to mine i have a strong bishop
that's gonna attack it i'm not gonna
exchange that
queen g3 uh possible but queen f4 is
much stronger because i want to go for
d4 if i play queen g3
i can't play this d4
so queen f4 makes a little more sense
because i want to push for
d4
yeah it should be it should be a little
easier to go for this
i see so many queen g trees i'm not sure
why you guys love this queen g3
too much it's a good idea to try and get
the queen
closer to the king but
all right so queen f4
yep this is also attacked
noteboard that is pc yep
hold on hold on knight d3 doesn't work
knight d3 i will take it if you take
back
now if takes g6 this guy's under attack
this guy is under attack
you take boom queen f7 coming next
careful careful
yep all right
um knights d3 doesn't work
well what about rook d3 does this work
because if i if you just move this rook
well i'm gonna
play d4 you move this then i'll take and
f7 falls
either two not either
so what do you think should happen
should you take this how else can this
deform these stops
also i'm going to send the link again
whoops
doesn't do it i gotta go copy it again
because i really don't want you guys to
miss out on this chance a pretty cool
chance
so make sure to try and enter
uh whenever you can it's a good idea
because the the club is doing raffle for
2018 santa claus
rapper and blitz tournament remember
when we could all
you know do actual human
traveling and chess these are pretty
cool vinyl boards all the players signed
it's such a cool thing
please go um sign
well i guess register sign in internal
raffle there we go
oh wait the link doesn't work
huh well let me let me go if the link
doesn't work because
then i could probably ask ben
oh garden variety
i see queen d4 yeah you i see that's
that's mentioned
yeah that's actually what my opponent
played
he played queen d4
yep surprisingly rook d3 was the best
one
ah thank you carter well rook t3 was the
best one because if i take now my takes
attacks my queen
now i gotta move the queen and then you
get to
try and stop my attack
it's not as strong also you ate upon
if i don't take it it's very strong so
i'm gonna give you a little hint
not taking is the best move but what do
you think is the
actual best movie in this position
taking is not a good idea but what's a
good idea
meanwhile i'm gonna do a quick check
with ben to make sure that the
link is working
and bishop my fate could work
f6 thank you yeah f6 is such a cool idea
cause
well you can't really take it because
that'll be a lot of fun for me
and if you don't take it but what else
are you gonna do
if you try and take rook takes d1 sure i
can even just take it over here
now i want to take to give you checkmate
you got to move this guy
now i can take it over here again you
can't really take it because queen f6 is
coming up
so let's say you play f5 i'll still take
this this is super duper cool
anyways uh that's the best line that
white should have continued with f6
but i guess my link is not working
all right i asked then to share the link
i don't know why the link wasn't working
huh well i guess i'm not permitted to
share links that would make sense
actually
all right so um queen of four pretty
cool we're trying to do d4
opponent try to stop it with queen d4
but now i get to eat your rook and to
top that
i still am like it's just like plus two
or what four white
how do you think we should win
this king looks too delicious we gotta
go try and attack it
queen h6 is a good idea but we could try
to improve that idea instead of queen
just going to h6
we could try to improve that by starting
with like f6
ah thank you thank you ben for sending
the link
so yeah as i said this is a pretty cool
sign signed board with
um for 2018 st
louis bliss and rapid that all the
players sign so yeah it
enter the raffle and well hopefully
you'll win it
all righty we have that message here
it's
pinned we got we got it good all right
so
f6 is a good idea another cool idea is
with queen h4 honestly i think queenish
four
kind of stops your king g8s but it's
trying to eat your pawns left and right
so i kind of like that too i'm a big
pawn eater
preferably chocolates but uh i'll eat
ponds too
uh f6 is another thing to be aware of
uh with f6 now let's say
take well let's say take we just take
now that checks coming up
that check's coming up i guess just rook
c1 could come up
let's see this knight is pinned maybe i
could try to poke that a little too
it's just so many things left and right
so f6 he didn't take he played
h5 and i wanted to remember this was
such a
weird thing for me because um i was
so much lower rated like 300 less he
wasn't i
am he was uh he was actually pretty
young i think around early
oh i don't know exactly not a teenager i
want to say but
maybe uh late teens early 20s
so he was he had energy he had decent
position
he had um the rating the title
but he kind of messed it up so i'm kind
of showing this to encourage you to not
be afraid of playing title
players just because he had an im title
it doesn't give him the right to win
it's not like his birthright i mean
yeah so it was kind of a cool idea to
try and show these games
now uh the game is going to be over in
like three four moves so let's try to
see
how should i wrap it up i think i'm
going to start with check there's no
king g8
checkmates then what what should we do
then
i manny no it was it was him i took his
writing
i liked it
all right so let's start with finish
eight and let's just eat the pond
because if you take it back
i can just ha it's kind of a cool idea
what do you think we should do there is
like a there are many different ways to
win but which one do you think is the
best one
yes rook takes f7 good job tank just
check
king moves and next you just bring the
queen
and rook comes too if you try to
go like king e6 it's the same watches
mate and one i thought
yeah i mean you could prolong it to blue
if you want but
no that's the same thing uh yeah
so yeah that was kind of a cool game
well in the game actually he played
uh rook c8 and at this point i was like
i don't want to risk anything i'm just
going to eat the rook you take it back
and i'll just make a new queen
easy peasy win
uh james that was kind of the fun thing
if you took here with the king after
rook c7 then
i can't take because i'll just eat your
queen
yeah that was kind of the cool thing
about it
so yeah that was another pretty cool
game of mine
i really like this one too it just it
felt nice not just because he was a
higher rated i am
but also because it was a higher rate
than i am
no because i played like a new opening
and i still managed to get it done and
i really liked it
all right i have one more game for you
guys from dragon style
and then after that we are uh
most likely we might have time to
actually do another one but
if we don't have time then we're gonna
switch it up to uh our usual like 10
minute break so i can set up twitch and
start gathering your games so you can
send it to me
and on twitch we're going to go there
you're still going to send your games
on from leachat to twitch there we go
so we can analyze your games all right
um this game was also pretty
fun if i remember correctly so
2014 i
i needed new openings like my my
i felt so weak against french and carl
khan
and um a lot of like the difference
like um sicilian especially dragon
i felt like i didn't have that like one
line that would be like super
and then uh i would need to
like add other little lines so
i uh as luck had it
uh pair margin negi started giving out
books
while writing out books i guess yeah um
he is he has a super cool opening series
i don't
know if it's finished yet um
yeah i think there's like one more
volume left but yeah he started like
e4 versus like french car con and park
that was awesome i won so many games in
those lines
and then there was another one and i
think there were like three of them
against sicilian that one of them was
specifically against najdorf
well i think maybe two of them were more
on niger and the other one was um
more on
what's this called um dragon yeah so
this one was kind of a more preparation
that's
like straight up i'm telling you uh
pretty much like 20 20 something moves i
knew
i knew the opening it was so funny
and it's um this was a game that i
played in world youth championship
2014 oh god i feel old uh
when i was under 16 and i remember this
was like the the
this game was right after the
uh the rest day because in world youths
we get like rest days because the
tournament's like 11 rounds so
it's a little too long so rest days are
usually appreciated
and uh this was right after the next the
rest day so like i remember rest day we
went to like mall
and did like a little shopping like we
went to aquarium or whatever
it was in south africa so it was so
beautiful uh but
eventually i was also preparing for this
game because my opponents only played
dragon and i really wanted to win
i didn't really like this lines that i
was playing i felt like i've been
playing them for so
long they kind of started to bore me so
this f3 g4 that i showed you in the
first game
bored me that idea with f4 was more of a
one-time thing
so i wanted something more stable and
i've been working on this
through nega's um books and i think
mimic was published on chess space too
because i remember
i had like i learned a lot of his scotch
on chess space opening wise
but his um dragons i don't know where
i think it was chess space or his books
it was a mix i want to say
uh anyways those are really great books
there
might be a little outdated to be honest
but i
would still recommend to you to
take a look at them try to find what's
wrong with them try to see if today's
engine have anything different to add
but most likely will but i don't think
the ideas are bad i think the ideas are
still pretty
sharp so um anyways
i'll show you this game and i'm telling
you this game was pretty much
all preparation there were so few moves
i think it was
literally like two moves that i did with
my brain
low i got a good memory um
so let's go ahead
so in the first game that i showed you
g4 was that
the second game we talked about the idea
with shirt castle now i'm showing you
more of a class classical approach with
bishop c force
so there are tons and tons and
tons of lines in these there's
take early on there's bishop d7 there
is i guess anything anything honestly
um the knight e5's there so there's so
many many many moves
and um so yeah
bishop d7 was played i like this idea of
castling
and doing king b1 early on because
black wants to play d5 early so we don't
want that we just want to
try and guess black to be very
uncomfortable and not d5 me
so after castle
um roxy8
and again i'm telling you straight
forward this is
all preparation my brain had very little
to do with this game
but um bishop b3 you should
know so uh you should know a lot of your
openings
even if not to the extent that i knew
also i got lucky it's like when you go
to the exam
and you you like you see teacher have
repeated like
10 of the questions from like a quiz
that he said he's not gonna do it but
then you like looked at it but then he
showed it
it's like this thing these things with
exams questions you can get lucky
and chess especially with preparation
you can get so
so so lucky so yeah i'm a huge advocate
for
you should prepare you should know chess
but you should prepare
yeah thank you captain memorizing that
many moves has a great deal to do with
your brain
true but i wasn't like i wasn't coming
up with moves i was coming up with
uh was this what i prepared it was more
than that
so anywho 95
now i know that to the theory some of
you might know the theory
but what do you think let's see if we
didn't know the theory
what do you think my opponent wants to
do after knight e5
ah thank you mj tyree
um tom see i'm gonna give you a little
advice
this was full preparation again there
might have been
some lines that have been updated or
actually outdated since then but i don't
think bishop b3 is one of them
bishop b3 is like classic dragon
yeah he wants to play knight to c4
so we can't really stop that but
what should we do so what is my idea as
white
eventually i want to start attacking too
but when when is the right time
oh john i was i was doing um
preparation i was preparing pretty much
around 1900
as early as i could
again you should know chess you should
not end games you should know middle
games you should know strategy before
you rely on
luck and preparation because if you get
a good position then how are you going
to win it you should be able to do that
but as as soon as you know you you're
able to actually win
uh with decent advantage then yeah
that's good enough
prepare f4 too early
especially this f3 pawn is good i don't
want to push that this is this pawn is
going to be
defending my g-force
so what else
what are some of like the typical ideas
in dragon like what is there anything
like does this scare you a little bit
yeah king b1 let's do that i don't know
exactly which pawn do i want to push
first but i know i want to
put this king in safety so
again here there are a bunch of
different lines rookie 8
a6 early b5 getting cleaned out
so so so many many different lines
but he put she she played knight c4
now shall we take it or should we give
up this bishop you go
you're gonna lose one of these one of
your two bishops so which one would you
choose to give up
ah thank you for your donation merca
super sweet of you
i'm glad you're liking the lessons make
sure to definitely come to our twitch
channel right after this so we can
analyze your game
all right so i see a lot of you wanting
to get rid of this bishop
i agree the thing is that we get the
brook to come up so we could start
poking it
this rook here is fine but it's not
really doing much
um
now which pawn should we start pushing
oh wow oh thank you thank you samir
thank you for the donations super cool
of you everybody
justin we are not arguing paul murphy is
awesome player pretty great yeah
all right so um
i see you there's like a pretty split
which one to start with
start with g4 because if you start with
h4
first of all there could be h5s now if
you play g4
i could just take that then it makes it
kind of it messes with the whole
written so start with g4 you know you're
going to do g4 anyway so you might as
well start with it
now next one we want to go for h4s and
h5s
and yeah
so what else
what do you think your opponent should
do
he should probably start attacking you
too right so what if b5
is that good can i eat it should i eat
it
black bishop trades for his bishop
[Music]
i'm not sure how that fit would be
oh i think i got you guys we shouldn't
eat it because if we eat it there
queen b8s doesn't matter with what
honestly
i mean with this is a little bit better
but still there's going to be queen b8s
you're gonna help your opponents attack
you
you're opening up stuff on your own king
so we shouldn't do that
after b5 don't take it don't give your
opponent momentum peace activity all of
those fun stuff don't give it to him
well her this case she was it was she
um so you're attacking me can i just
ignore you and play h4
oh why are you guys against h4 i don't
get it h4 is pretty cool
idea oh
ah sorry my youtube just went offline
wait
uh let me double check with ben if i'm
being weird from my aunt or
yeah i don't know uh well since you guys
aren't saying anything
i guess the video is all right
anyways i'm checking in with them to
make sure
a stream is not crashing hello
all right
uh black does still doesn't
have immediate threats um
you see the thing is we don't need to
play g5 that's the thing
we don't know if you're gonna do this g5
we know we got to open up the rook so
let's go for that
yeah let's go for h4
h4 is pretty good
huh peaches watching over the connection
which is
little uh looking super cute
all right um
okay let's go h4 is a good idea i don't
think you should start with g5
um
that's the thing when you play b4 i'm
not gonna go on knight t2 i'm going
knight d5
because after knight d5 if take
take yes this bishop is opened but my
knight is kind of still protecting it
and imagine if this pawn was not on the
board this would be much worse right
if this pawn not that this pawn is here
it's blocking
uh it's gonna protect your miking
honestly so this is good
i like this
now in the game black plate queen a8
again this is all perforation so
don't feel bad if you can't find the
right moves but what do you think we
should do
black wants to eat my pond do i care
about this pond or should i continue
with my attack
all right all right okay i see some
ideas would
continue or try to
kick the rock um
yeah let's go for h5 the thing is this
pawn
like b3 possible but no no no
ow ow
yeah i don't i don't really like this
so let's continue with our idea with h5
now
what if you take
can i use this somehow
yeah so that's the idea where should we
go though
yep we're not playing v3 nope
yeah nice knight f5 going after e7
let's say take now careful should we
take back immediately
or or checks
yeah let's take first check you move the
king now what should i eat this with
and i'd like to point out this is still
preparation
so yes
yeah we should take it with the rook
because
the thing is we want to be able to
potentially
use this diagonal so careful with that
so rook takes d2 um
now in the game it was kind of funny
because uh my opponents here played
rookie 8
well i don't really i mean i have to um
yeah i just have to do like literally
have one move so let's do this
i'm also depend defending this guy
um
[Music]
so my opponent here got a little excited
and played a5
what do you think we should do this was
literally the only move of the game that
i did myself
so i'm not i'm out of preparation right
now how do you think we should win
a little funny honestly
so what should we do as
white
uh-huh i see some ideas coming in
trap the bishop basically yeah let's go
trap the bishop
literally the only move i had to think
about
[Music]
now he moved the bishop drop it he took
she took over here
i took that um
rookie five and well does bishop d4 give
me this guy too
and well she just resigned here after
well checkmate is coming up it was quite
fun
this uh literally the only move that i
had to
spend some brain cells on was
this idea with drugs with h6
so a little funny for me to not
is this like it happens here and there
like
there has definitely been some games
that i've
really had easy win there there has been
some games that
have been a little harder but kind of
managed
no i didn't sing and thank you next
or easy yeah
yeah i i didn't do that no that would be
too painful
um this was just a good game and she was
out prepped
she i think i i think her
honestly her mistake was that she didn't
know
her opening she knew it but she didn't
know it well like
when you play only one opening you
should know it well
you should know what you're doing yeah
i'm going to show you another example
this was
also not a super high class game well i
mean i i had a
nice win uh but this one's like a
little different type of like
accelerated dragon
um so
a lot of the times here if you take with
knights
there are like they try to do
accelerated dragon
starting with like knight f6 because if
like bishop here you have c4
so no um it goes to maroxy
structures which we have also done
um which we have also done like i
believe like
few hours on i'd also like to take a
second to mention that the cat who
made fishy believe is behind my window
should i go make it bleed
i'm not going to make a catholic but i'm
sure she's not he's not welcome here
anymore you make my cat lead you go
get food somewhere else anyways
um so now that i did my little sassy
part uh let's go ah makes me feel bad
though
why would you have to go ruin it you
weird cat i was feeding you you were
warming up you had a nice thing going
and you have to go make my
cat bleed
all right back to chess parts poor
peachy
uh people play this line quite quite
frankly because
they are hoping to save this d6 they
don't want to do this d6 they want to
start
with this and then they're gonna try and
do the same things with dragon
uh just without d6 and later on they're
gonna like do
immediate d5 i fell into that trap once
or twice
so um i wouldn't exactly recommend it
i mean let me rephrase it's not a trap
but you should know it's what you should
know what you're doing so for me when i
want to play bishop c4 this d5 is a
little bothersome
so i wouldn't really want to do that
i kind of bugs me to not be able to play
this c4
all right so um that is why
i usually take with queen now after
taking with queen
there is a whole line going on first of
all i'm going to show you the
easiest way which is with knight f6
knight c6
you go there you come here you have to
do this little queen dance
and uh then after east
well the best move is like trying to go
knight b6 or knight b4
but my opponent here was quite oh i
think he was
very a little unexperienced he played e6
or not as experienced he went for e6 now
what do you think we should do what do
you think is the strategy
also these these nice these are so
such nice outposts
okay i'm glad everybody is agreeing that
the stray cat is on a timeout
i will probably still feed it but i'll
not let it come inside because
poor peachy
yeah i can't forget his face after he
got
he's never like been in a violent
situation
so when he experienced violence and when
he was bleeding he came to me like
his eyes were like you were so sad
yeah and he he still has a little scar
going on
but yeah that cat anyways what do you
think we should do how should we develop
oh well honestly there are many many
ways you can develop
uh c4 is the easiest way to go i didn't
want to quite be bothered with anything
happening on b4
and i also wanted to confuse my opponent
so i started with a3
i was like you know what i'm gonna go
for a3
because you are well nothing can no i
don't want anything on my b4
this is not the most accurate way this
is just something that i did to
avoid some of the things that you could
do
anyways so he played bishop g7
um his mistake was this e6 like
e6 makes no sense because
you you already played g6 so you're
committed to trying to tell in the
bishop
so it makes absolutely no sense to play
e6
because then you're just making new
holes yes i was attacking your knight so
move the knights
alright so bishop g7 now i poke your
knight
now i just get my pieces out especially
because i don't want to worry about this
pawn
being under attack so bishop f4
a6 and now what
how do you think we should get our
pieces out which side are we castling
which side should we
to be fair it's not that hard to answer
because
there's like a b5 coming up so we should
go the other way
so but we should still develop so let's
still get this knight out
and then i'll get my bishop out
and i agree this ideas with h4 is so
so tempting but i honestly just wanted
to
play somewhat of a safe game i have such
good position so much space
so much holes to go poke
so many so um i didn't want to risk it i
just wanted to play somewhat of a safe
game
win this game i'm at some morning crown
2. i am not a morning person
it after 10 am i'm good i can do
anything after 10 am
9 00 am i can still do it i'll need
coffee
probably a massage some chocolate 8 a.m
oh
no i am not a morning person i've never
been a morning person
it's gonna make my life quite miserable
but thank god for night shifts
so
exactly thank you i'm adding if i can if
i can
avoid calculating perfect
all right so um here
after uh
i castled he played f5
so um after f5 what do you think we
should do
ah that stray cat's still here
so how can i how can i make a stray cat
forget that i've been feeding
it for a few months
anybody knows how to propel a cat
wow 5 am man show the cat there's one
cat here that's the only cat
that should be on camera maybe he can
show us his other side
you see switch a little
yeah i've unfortunately um trained the
cat to come and now if i could only
train it to not
make my cat bleed we could not leave
halfway there after
but cats
why oh why why don't you guys want to do
uh you know this and you know eat
so i don't get it this is supposed to be
an easy thing
ah thank you ambassadon yes i manny can
i come take this cat
then i'll feel not guilty about not
feeding it because i really don't want
to feed it since you made my cat plate
but sitting there waiting and it's like
staring at me ow my heart hurts
all right so we should we should do this
amazon and we should just eat over here
right it's easy peasy stuff
uh you know also my opponent was quite
helpful to be honest
i just ate everything no this was a good
game
uh i have some other games that have
been
uh as i want to say nice there was
one game that um
was actually a little extra sweet let me
see
was it this one yeah so this one
i better just show the opening of it
because
uh we're a little low on time because i
gotta make a switch
from oh look now it's coming closer to
them
oh it hurts my soul sorry it's
hard to see an animal that i liked
and now i have to dislike
all right pc after falling off
let's go um so this was a different game
like
this is not the main opening that people
play
but this is also doable so i'm just
showing you this
for opening purposes because
well i think it's important to know a
little bit
about all openings but
all right so um queen e4
so honestly there's so many different
ways to play this
knight b4 is one of it's the idea behind
knight before
is kind of um funny because if it's
black two if like's gonna try to play
d5 and bishop f5 oh
hello
um so as wise we should try to stop that
we play bishop b5 we stop this idea with
d5
because if you play d5 now this is pin
so i get to eat this for free
um now black would play a6
bishop a4 b5 bishop b3 now my bishop is
protecting this pawn so
d5 doesn't work as well
because now after d5 i'll simply be able
to take it over here
mesh up f5 and i'll just save my queen
i believe uh then they're like
my day fives and castling that's not the
most
common way to play this there are other
ways too i think
b5 is something that has to be played
after b5 bishop b3 d5
take maybe not bishop f5 maybe um queen
d6 is another way like bishop f4
then try to do like weird things with
the queen and it's like a whole thing
but um yeah it's
it's a um it's you should know this but
it's not that hard to find moves
all that all all black wants with this
knight before
is to go after c2 with or ideally with
bishop f5
so yeah
that's one thing i wanted to show the
other thing is with knight c7s
but with knight c7s we just kind of get
knight f3
bishop f4 and um
long castle and that's one of the games
that i actually played
i'll show you a little bit more but
i we're not going to be able to wrap it
up for this game
it's a very long game and i messed it up
i had advantage and it ended in the draw
so anywho um
so when we're looking at
these lines
what do you think what what should be
what well
i say we have advantage but where is our
advantage
so what do you think
yeah this guy is a space master i agree
this guy has so much space and this
line will most likely pop up i'm not the
biggest fan on
this diagonal so i might just move it a
little
so what next
this could come up um probably stuart
castle will be because long castle i
mean i guess 96
maybe try to go for long castle
i guess it's possible but
um still knight b5s
a little uneasy
oh maybe 95 a little better actually
try to keep it with the rhythm anyways
uh
white is uh holding that kind of like a
mini advantage
because of the space but i couldn't hold
it
and actually in the game um this is
actually what happened in the game after
queen v8 i went back like queenie tree i
still have advantage
and i um i knew i was better i just
didn't really know
how to continue and that's why i
messed it up and ended in a draw
oh such a good game uh anywho
um and there's another line that i also
want to mention
before we finish up with knight
b6 so knight v6 is another quite popular
line
and with knight b6
uh you got to be careful because now
knight c3 has to be played
after knight c3 something with d6 or
bishop g7
it's kind of like a um
so what would have been a better way to
continue for white to press great wolf
you would have to come back
next week for more on that yeah i do
want to talk about giving you a
committee trailer on
um more of
this is not accelerated dragon but this
line with dragon
like accelerated trying to do dragon um
so yeah this knight b6 is another cool
idea
that it could be a nice way to go for it
i think knight piece is actually the
most popular these days
and then continuing with d6 or bishop g7
and then trying to go for again later on
you would do something with this pawn
try to get the bishop out
uh white could try to go for long castle
or short castle black will
highly likely to just go for short
castle
and yeah that's where i'll leave you for
the cliffhanger
um so please come to our twitch channel
uh pretty much now in about 10 minutes
i'm gonna
um switch the switch from youtube to
twitch and have the setup
uh the cat will most likely be here i
will also most likely give in and feed
that cat because it's staring at me i
don't
i don't want the dead cats to come back
haunt me
um but yes please come on
in our twitch channel have your games
ready to send
a pgn format we will go over it it's in
a type of um
first comes for serve if you have not
seen our
our twitch channel oh boy you should
it's a good channel
um you should follow it ideally
subscribe to it
and um yeah i'll see if we can get the
gmp bitmoji going on no i'm kidding
um but yeah uh on twitch channel we are
simply at
stl just with me
actually um that's a little sad wait
you've never been on twitch channel why
why haven't you been on our twitch
channel
we've had two channels going on for
months if not
years at least we've been actually
wanted for
i want to say last two years at least
all right um following
i don't want to make noise with this
yeah just look up a setlist chess club
uh jesus how do i share this
ah there we go whisper
nope add share there we go
copy and yes
please come to our
twitch tvs um stl
chess club on
twitch all right
i'll see you in about 10 minutes i have
your
games ready to go so this first come
first serve type of deal and with that
i'll see you in a